In other words we can use the binary code,
the computer language,
to code for any sort of information.
And it's also useful for transmission of information.
If we send a sound wave or any sort of wave
by a train of digits
it uses a very much wider bandwidth.
As you can see the information that has to
go there to transmit those digits
has to be very, very much faster than the
wave itself.
Much faster even then had we coded it in frequency
modulation form.
But it carries a number of advantages.
For one thing, if you send the ordinary wave,
then anything that gets added to it in the
form of interference,
cannot be separated from the wave at the far
end.
And if you transmit it far enough by radio
or via cable, by any means,
it gets worse the further it gets.
With a binary train however, provided you
can recognise
whether it is meant to be a nought or a one.
Then as long as you can make that recognition
it doesn't matter how much they've degraded.
So every so often you can have a repeater
that does the recognition,
makes brand new smart pulses and sends it
on completely unaffected.
There is no degradation with distance.
So what can you do then if you have a processor
of this sort?
It can handle information, provided it knows
the code, of a very wide variety.
You can have access to data banks.
You can call them up and pull the information
maybe down the telephone line.
Did you know for instance that it is possible
to call down pictures from satellites
so that you can see the weather picture
without waiting for it to come up on the television.
In fact you can do better than that.
There is a satellite called NOAA-9.
N O A A 9.
Which is in polar orbit. It passes over this
country twice each day.
Once going North, one South.
But in fact we can see it on three orbits
each time.
So that's six times altogether.
And for a couple of hundred pounds you can
buy a system consisting of an aerial like
that
which you stick up on the roof, in the loft.
Connect it to a receiver.
At a more convenient point.
And a decoder.
And that can be connected in turn to a tape
recorder so that when the satellite goes over
it turns the tape recorder on and gathers
the picture.
Here is a stored picture that was brought
up from...
There we are. We see the Earth. We can see
Africa there.
Fine weather over Spain, but the rest of Europe
looking a bit cloudy.
We go from Saudi Arabia and Madagascar on
the right
over to South America on the left.
You can pull that down yourself.
You can also get a closer up picture of Europe.
Which is really amazing.
Look how much fine weather there is over the
whole of the British Isles
and Northern Europe.
That must have been chosen on a very, very
clear day.